the London Metal Exchange is the King  Kong of metal trading it stores over 17  and a half billion dollars worth of  metal in 700 warehouses around the world  here's how it works a producer like  Alcoa typically sells its metal directly  to a buyer like anheuser-busch but  sometimes Alcoa makes too much and must  store the leftover at an independent lme  approved warehouse typically companies  by months in advance but in a pinch go  to the LME by a long contract and when  the metal becomes available they take it  home now some of that metal sitting in  the warehouse is not for sale it's used  in financing an investor buys the metal  stores it and then sells it for a better  price in the future pocketing the  difference it's a complicated business  but one essential to the flow of metal  around the world